[Music]
the Grantchester has changed up the
format and now we have three rapid and
lits events before a classical event
what are your thoughts about that
no well ideally it would be over happy
didn't believe but okay no I mean still
it's I mean I like it really much but
I'm happy to play faster type controls
Eli I don't get to every day usually I'm
playing classical events so this is kind
of a welcome opportunity to try
something different
rapid and blades is becoming preferred
time control for muscle people because
you don't need to prepare so deeply and
can be more creative also you know from
from before the start that your games
are going to contain mistakes and
blunders that's a that also gives you a
carte blanche to to play a bit more open
chest so I think when it comes to
entertainment value is probably more fun
totally different game because in a
classical game we prepare beforehand
very specifically on that one
serious opponent on that specific color
and that specific day he make one
mistake in a classical game it's very
hard to come back because on that day
because there's only one game that day
but here it's game after game after game
and yeah it's a totally different skills
and classical chess I'd say the point of
the tour is to showcase chest and I
think it's it's nice for the most part
the general trend in normal classical
that seems to be leading more and more
towards a higher percentage of draws and
so therefore I like I like to wrap it in
blitz concept I think it should be a lot
more fun I think you're gonna have a lot
more decisive games which in the bigger
picture I think is much more important
than the quality of the overall play I
think it's a which is a very good for
chess fans they like it when it's
fighting chess
it's very first play high I think it's
an interesting development I mean the
grand gesture is how it always had a lot
of rabbit and both of us but now it's me
it's the majorities wrapping blitz
and and we have a different
qualification system to the final years
last time there was you know everyone
played the final and in London and and
now only four players will play which
which kind of raises the stakes a bit
it's gonna be more like the NBA more
like the playoff format what are your
thoughts about this particular change
for the Grantchester
yeah it sounds very interesting it's
like I think it's the best when you have
like qualification where around 50%
qualify so here it would be four out of
nine qualify I think it's like the best
ratio you know as they do about the same
raishin NHL in NBA it's around 50% they
qualified to playoff it's fine obviously
I'd like to be in the first of all and
we'll see if I can make that happen in
general I like not even so we don't have
enough of that and I think this one it's
so very small not even that show up at
the end of the year but well I will do
my my best to qualify for it it puts a
lot of pressure on many players because
you can't have a bad tournament I see it
as a positive sign because in previous
years you could have one bad tournament
and continue being in race here it's you
know Now or Never
you you have to prove a point from the
start it's more exciting I guess it's
more playoff type you gotta be mentally
strong and mentally ready to play all
those games I guess it's a change we'll
we'll see how it goes
I hope to qualify for London to be there
perfectly myself I think it's it's a
great idea and again if you look at the
overall Grantchester say last year even
two years ago normally came down to a
handful of games and usually it was not
the game against the closest competitor
usually it was a game against someone
say in the middle of that the standings
are at the bottom and someone wanted
game against this player and the other
person did and so I think just overall
having a match format at the end will be
very exciting and hopefully I make it
that far I think we'll just have to wait
and see how exciting
the run-up to the finals is and and the
actual competition the final four is so
it's not something that's that's very
common in chess and it's a bit of an
experiment and hopefully it'll be a good
one for sure it's going to be an
interesting one interesting to see who
makes it and and who comes out the
winner I don't know how exciting it will
be well this is a good change and I
think we should try to show our best in
every tournament we have to play well
and then if we do it then we'll have a
chance to play in one